de l'énergie durable pour tous c'est le
thème d'un grand forum qui se tient
cette semaine à new york sous l'égide
des nations unies
chantal srivastava bonsoir soir céline
là ce forum spécial il a été convoqué
par le secrétaire général des nations
unies ban ki moon qui a fait de cet
enjeu son cheval de bataille c'est
vraiment un dossier qui lui tient
extrêmement hackers céline et son appel
a été entendu puisque cette semaine à
new york
deux mille personnes participent à ce
sommet spécial des gens qui viennent au
secteur industriel des gens de la
société civile
même des invités de marque imaginer le
rappeur américain akon qui est venu
présenter son initiative et quand il l'a
été africain
il veut électrifier les millions de
foyers en afrique grâce à l'énergie
solaire
alors tout ça va culminer au cours des
deux prochains jours avec un sommet
formel ou seront des représentants
d'états au siège de l'onu pour parler
des enjeux en cause est le but ultime
c'est vraiment de donner un accès à
l'électricité pour tout le monde sur la
planète mais c'est un objectif très
noble mais extrêmement ambitieux parce
qu on part de très loin on parle de très
loin la banque mondiale eux profiter de
ce sommet pour publier les données les
plus récentes
à l'heure actuelle aujourd'hui un
milliard trois cents millions de
personnes n'ont pas d'électricité ces
lignes c'est un humain sur cinq
de plus on note qu'à peu près presque 3
milliards de personnes doivent encore
pour se faire à manger
chauffez du bois du charbon des
excréments d'animaux sécher ses 40% de
la population mondiale plus que les
populations combiné de l'inde et de la
chine
et quand on sait qu'on fait ça à
l'intérieur des maisons ça pollue l'air
donc c'est en plus un enjeu de santé
alors je vous écoute est ce que c'est
pas un défi énorme don de vouloir
justement donné électrifié de
l'électricité à tout le monde ça l'est
d'autant plus quand nous avons lutte
présentement contre les changements
climatiques et la hausse des gaz à effet
de serre alors je peux vous donner une
idée des objectifs qu'on s'est fixés
comme société on veut de l'énergie
durable pour tous en 2030 un accès
universel à l'électricité l'efficacité
énergétique accrue pour tout le monde
on veut également doubler la part des
énergies renouvelables ça c'est très
important parce qu'à l'heure actuelle on
n'y a environ 18%
ce bouquet énergétique et c'est loin
d'être
suffisant mais tout ça a un coût bien
sûr bien sûr un coût qui peut sembler à
prime abord extrêmement élevé les
investissements à l'heure actuelle dans
le secteur de l'énergie renouvelable
sont dehors de 4,5 milliards de dollars
alors ça c'est pour 2015
en 2030 il faudrait avoir multiplié par
trois pour atteindre 1 1250 milliards
par année c'est énorme mais il faut
savoir que c'est quatre fois moins que
les fonds publics qui sont engloutis
annuellement par le secteur des énergies
fossiles et que chaque dollar investi
dans ce secteur rapporte trois fois plus
donc c'est vraiment c'est rentable
tout ça dans un contexte comme vous
disiez de lutte aux gaz à effet de serre
la beauté c'est qu'on peut faire d'une
pierre deux coups on lutte contre la
pauvreté et on s'attaque également à
l'enjeu 2 des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre en augmentant le portefeuille
d'énergies renouvelables d'énergie verte
et sens quand on sait que le deux tiers
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
sont liées au secteur de l'énergie
c'est vraiment un enjeu très important
donc 2030 électricité pour tous
souhaitent c'est la moindre des choses
merci bon je vous en prie